[Music]
today I'll do something super exciting
I'm actually going back to Coney Island
in New York to ride the slingshot I went
on this ride last year and seen the
video you'll know that I passed out it
was terrifying
so I'm gonna go do that again you don't
know what I think shot is it's basically
a ball that you're put into and then
you're flung into the air about 300
times it just like catapult you to the
sky bounce up and down I got him to do
it last year actually turn out very well
first of all like when you're being
strapped in we don't know when you're
gonna be like how to pull it to the sky
so I was so nervous my hands were so
shaky and like freaking I was screaming
so loud I had such a hard time talking
the next day you can imagine how much I
got made fun of I'm not sure how that's
gonna go
because last time I screamed I passed
out it was a lot of different feelings
that went through that period of time
it's been a year since then we've had
some time to process what happens this
time around
no screaming at all no facial
expressions no nothing I'm gonna prove
my brothers and I can do this without
was screaming like a baby I still made a
promise not to make any sort of reaction
any crazy things I think I'll be ready
no no sleeping no nothing I'm gonna save
the boat - wait - go myself okay I guess
let's do this
that is the head of that bag
[Music]
what do you think did read - okay I
don't think we did that well you did
better than I did I didn't pass out like
the first time so I mean that's better
than nothing to feel the challenge nuts
your supersenses as soon as we took off
the rain is going so fast it like hits
you in the face you feel like you're
going so fast and then I lost it and
just started screaming my day came when
the ride with me and it helped a lot but
just having someone there it wasn't as
scary I guess and having that moral
support would I do it again his
questionable throw me on any
rollercoaster I'm completely fine but
those type of rides it's just not I
think I'm good for now I can take a
break from that to that kind of thing
[Music]
[Music]